D
THOSE LIES HAVE PUT OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY AT RISK.
HERE WITH REACTION TO ALL OF
THIS, NO STRANGER TO WAR ZONES
OR SELF, IS FOX NATION HOST LARA
LOGAN.
YOUR TAKE ON TODAY?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT I DIDN'T
HEAR IN THE HEARING TODAY, I
DIDN'T HEAR AN APOLOGY TO THE
AFGHAN PEOPLE FOR THE LIES THAT
HAVE BEEN TOLD ABOUT THEM.
I DIDN'T HEAR AN APOLOGY TO THE
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED PRESIDENT
OF AFGHANISTAN WHO HAS NOT QUIT
AND IS STILL IN THE FIGHT.
I DIDN'T HEAR AN APOLOGY TO ALL
OF THE AMERICAN SERVICEMAN, THE
VETERANS AND THE ACTIVE-DUTY
SHOULDER TO SOLDIERS WHO HAVE
LITERALLY STOOD SHOULDER TO
SHOULDER WITH THE AFGHAN
OPERATIONS FORCES WHO ARE STILL
FIGHTING TODAY, AND APOLOGIZE TO
THEM FOR DRAGGING THEM DOWN IN
THE ABSOLUTE SHAME OF BETRAYAL,
WHICH IS WHERE WE ARE, AND YOU
KNOW WHAT ELSE WE DIDN'T HEAR?
ANY MENTION OF WHAT WE ARE GOING
TO DO ABOUT IT, RIGHT?
EVERYBODY IS ACTING LIKE THIS IS
OVER, SOME KIND OF DONE DEAL,
AND SO WE NEED ACCOUNTABILITY,
BUT WHAT ABOUT WE NEED ACTION TO
REVERSE WHAT HAPPENED NOW?
WHY DO WE ACCEPT, AS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THAT ALL OF
THESE WEAPONS, 80 PLUS BILLION
DOLLARS OF ADVANCED MILITARY
HARDWARE IS TO BE IN THE HANDS
OF OUR ENEMY?
HAS TO BE IN THE HANDS OF
TERRORISTS AND HAS TO BE IN THE
HANDS OF OUR ADVERSARIES LIKE
CHINA AND PAKISTAN AND IRAN?
THAT IS NOT AN ACCEPTABLE
SITUATION, NOT A K FOR
GENERAL MILLEY TO SIT THERE LIKE
A SCHOOLBOY AND SAY YES, AMERICA
IS LESS SAFE.
WE DON'T NEED THAT FROM A
GENERAL, WE NEED A GENERAL WHO'S
GOING TO LEAD.
THAT IS WHAT WE THE PEOPLE ARE
ASKING FOR, LEADERS WHO ARE
GOING TO LEAD.
AND THEY ARE GOING TO GET
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE THE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GET
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE IT'S
THEIR GOVERNMENT, IT'S ACTUALLY
THERE MILITARY AND IT'S ACTUALLY
THEIR INSTITUTION, AND I WANT
EVERYBODY TO KNOW THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF AFGHANISTAN, WHO IS
THE DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED
LEADER, HE CALLED ME, HE WATCHED
THE HEARINGS TODAY AND HE CALLED
ME TO OFFER HIS THANKS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND TO THE
CONGRESSMAN OF BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE, DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICAN,
WHO HAVE THE COURAGE TO STAND UP
FOR WHAT WAS RIGHT AND TO GET
SOME DEGREE, SOME TINY LITTLE
BIT OF THE TRUTH AND HE WANTED
ME TO TELL YOU ON HIS BEHALF
THAT HE IS VERY GRATEFUL BECAUSE
HE NEVER LOST HIS FAITH IN THE
GOOD OF WHAT AMERICA STANDS FOR
AND BELIEVES IN, AND THE OTHER
THING THAT YOU SHOULD KNOW IS
THAT THE RESISTANCE THAT THEY
WANT TO WRITE OUT OF HISTORY,
RIGHTS, THE CIA AND ALL THE
OTHER INFORMATION WARFARE
OPERATIVES OUT THERE HAVE BEEN
VERY BUSY PUSHING THEIR FALSE
NARRATIVES THAT THE AFGHANS ALSO
RENDERED, THEY WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT IN THE LAST 48 HOURS,
THEY'VE KILLED HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF TALIBAN
ALL ACROSS AFGHANISTAN, THAT THE
FIGHT HAS NOT STOPPED, IT'S
CONTINUING TO THIS DAY, AND THAT
A REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED
GOVERNMENT OF AFGHANISTAN AND
ITS PRESIDENT WILL BE PRESENT AT
THE UNITED NATIONS IN NEW YORK
AT THE GENERAL ASSEMBLY AND THEY
WILL HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY AT
THAT MEETING.
ONE THING, SEAN, THAT IS BEING
LEFT OUT OF THIS WHOLE
CONVERSATION THAT IS THE MOST
CRITICAL OF ALL WHEN IT COMES TO
WHAT WE DO MOVING FORWARD, IS
PAKISTAN.
BECAUSE THE TRUTH IS, YES, THERE
WAS CORRUPTION IN AFGHANISTAN,
PEOPLE CAN POINT FINGERS AT THE
RESISTANCE, AT THE TALIBAN, AND
SO ON, AND THERE'S PLENTY OF
BLAME TO GO AROUND, RIGHT?
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
BUT THIS IS WHAT HAS BEEN TRUE
FROM DAY ONE, IT'S THE SIMPLEST
THING OF ALL ABOUT THE ENTIRE
CONFLICT.
YOU CANNOT DEFEAT AN ENEMY WHO
ISN'T IN THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S IT.
IF YOUR ENEMY IS NOT IN
AFGHANISTAN, THERE'S NOTHING YOU
CAN DO ABOUT THAT.
YOU CAN'T WIN THAT FIGHT.
YOU HAVE TO GO ACROSS THE BORDER
INTO PAKISTAN WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY RESIDE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, IF WE WERE
GOING TO LEAVE $80 BILLION WORTH
OF MILITARY EQUIPMENT, THE MOST
SOPHISTICATED, THE LATEST,
GREATEST, BEST TECHNOLOGY ON THE
FACE OF THE EARTH, MAYBE WE
COULD HAVE LEFT IT WITH THE
PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY WANTED A
FREE AFGHANISTAN, NOT THE
TERRORISTS THAT NOW CONTROL THE
BLACK HAWK HELICOPTERS AND THE
DRONES AND THE NIGHT VISION
GOGGLES AND TO BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF EQUIPMENT.
THANK YOU.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
>> WE STILL CAN.
WE HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO CHANGE
THIS RIGHT NOW WITH THERMO UABS
AND ALL BECAUSE OF OTHER
EQUIPMENT.
WE DON'T HAVE TO ACCEPT THIS
OUTCOME.
I WISH SOMEONE HAD ASKED
GENERAL MILLEY HOW MUCH OF OUR
ADVANCED CAPABILITY HAVE WE
ACTUALLY USED AND THEY WILL TELL
YOU IT'S 10% OR LESS.
SO WHAT DO YOU GOT IT ALL FOR IF
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO USE IT?
EXACTLY.
>> Sean: THEY ARE NOT LIFTING
A FINGER.
IF THEY'VE ABANDONED OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS.
THEY'VE ABANDONED THEIR
FAMILIES, THEY HAVE ABANDONED
GREEN CARD HOLDERS.
THEY'VE ABANDONED OUR AFGHAN
ALLIES, AND THIS IS NOT GOING TO
END WELL.
YOU KNOW IT AND I KNOW IT.
I PRAY TO GOD I COME IN THE AIR
ONE DAY AND I GET TO SAY I WAS
WRONG.
BECAUSE THEY WILL BE SAFE IF I
CAN SAY THOSE WORDS.
THANK YOU, LARA LOGAN.
DON'T FORGET HER SHO